odell beckham jr is not in the last year
of his contract there are issues there
in cleveland and
yesterday both odell beckham jr and
baker mayfield were available for media
because they play thursday night so the
calendar of when guys talk gets adjusted
here's odell beckham jr discussing his
chemistry or lack thereof with
quarterback baker mayfield
i think once i get
you all the world everyone to understand
that i care
about one thing and that's
winning and producing
i think that you'll be able to see some
of the other actions
and look at it from a different
perspective than a perspective of a lot
of the names and attachments that have
been thrown on me in a way
yeah i understand that and uh look i i i
hope that odell beckham jr is maturing
to the point where he doesn't get upset
because he's a focal point of attention
because he's craved that attention
throughout his career
um but uh the production's just not
there and chris i watched that game last
night yeah odell beckham jr
dropped a pass
at a key moment in the game right third
and two right yeah right here and let me
set it up it was 10 to 6 because this
wasn't a blowout right it became a
blowout it was 10 to 6
and the browns were embarking on a drive
and they were starting to make some hay
odell beckham jr got a horrible for him
face mask call caught a short little
screen pass and grabbed the defender's
face mask sets him back 15 yards first
and 29 became fourth and 41. then they
get a punt down to the one-yard line hey
we're in business we stop we get a short
field maybe we can take the lead well
that's when the ravens drive all the way
down the field 99 yards and make it 17-6
and then the browns offense woke up and
they're moving down the field and
they've got third and two around the
baltimore 20 and otto beckham jr does
the ran before he had it thing right
embracing the inevitable contact before
he secures the ball thing something that
no receiver making that kind of money
should ever do drops the pass they
missed the field goal floodgates open
game over that was the key moment and
that's on otto beckham jr yeah that is
that i mean there's there's no denying
that i saw the play happen out you know
i saw it play out in real time on sunday
going man
you know that's just that's just going
to make things harder because i think
you know odell beckham jr first off and
the baker mayfield we've talked about it
a lot the connection's never been good
ever since he's gotten there i mean it's
never really clicked and then i think it
you know kind of compounds itself
because odell then doesn't get the ball
and then when he sees the ball coming
his way he wants to do so much with it
because he hasn't had the ball so there
like you said he he's got the some of
the greatest hands we've ever seen but
then he makes a drop where you go how
can you drop that i mean a fourth grader
would have caught that but it is it's
because he's trying to make something
happen
and it just doesn't seem like they click
in cleveland i don't i don't know i
don't know where this goes and you know
i i saw what you wrote and like even
heard what you said a little yesterday
but on the power rankings
like it seems like everything in
cleveland went wrong ever since odell
beckham jr went there
and i don't like to say that i can and
i'm not going to necessarily agree with
you but i kind of i know what you're
saying
you know they have not been able to
click ever since he's been there and i
think it's put more pressure on baker
mayfield one because he feels like whoa
i got these weapons around me so i got
to start playing good and then two as
we've talked about before
when you have a great receiver in your
quarterback you want to make them happy
and you want to make it work so bad it's
like that best friend that you're like
oh he's so cool i hope he likes me as
much as i like him and when you throw
the ball i had these feelings when i
first threw the keyshawn and joey
galloway and and other you know uh
um tim brown where i just oh i wanted to
throw every ball so perfect so they like
me oh please hit him right in the chest
and i think that's all just been an
issue there
but when the hell is it going to get
fixed and i think we're getting towards
danger zone time here to where i go okay
maybe it's i don't know another few
weeks i might just go abort mission
abort mission let's put odell beckham jr
on the trade block and let's move on
cleveland odell and let's go
yeah i think that they already should
come to that conclusion and remember
there was a report in the off-season
that the
vikings and the browns were talking
about an odell beckham jr trade and that
went away as quickly as emerged but i
don't believe that that report was
inaccurate or made up or fabricated i
think the browns considering all their
options considering the reality that the
chemistry just isn't there between him
and baker mayfield and it's not going to
be and let's hear directly from baker
mayfield on that point chris he was
asked yesterday can there be a tricky
balance
between wanting to get obj the ball and
needing to get him the ball here's baker
mayfield's response
i think it has to come naturally um you
know obviously
you game plan and you scheme up things
you get the balls in your playmakers
hands um
but then when it comes to game time
they're going to give us certain looks
that might take that away you know we
had a couple plays
uh for him early on and the ravens did a
good job of taking that away so we had
to go through the reeds and and get the
ball in other guys hands uh so it's just
when it comes to game time yeah you can
practice practice practice and you might
have a certain look all week in practice
but then come game time
uh they might show you a different thing
and you got to react and play and just
move on it's got to come back to it
he's absolutely right and that's the way
it should be
remember the randy ratio
yeah you can't force the ball to a
certain guy a receiver it's one thing to
say we want to get our running game
going and we're committed to our running
game that's easy to do because they
can't keep you from handing the ball off
to a running back they can keep you from
getting the ball into the hands of a
receiver and the more urgency you
express as a team to get the ball to a
certain guy
the defense knows what's going on what
are they going to do they're going to
design plays defensively to take that
away because they know
you don't just stop that play you create
frustration yeah you prevent that
chemistry from happening and i hey look
the question i raised chris march of
2019 is cleveland big enough for both
baker mayfield and otto beckham jr and
it's possible that those two just never
clicked yeah mayfield resents this
expectation that he's got to get the
ball to one certain guy we got all these
weapons just let me get it to the guy
who's open and not be stressed out about
trying to get it to one guy yeah well i
know and i hopefully he's not and you
know again i don't look at it as like a
personality thing and i don't i don't
think it's like ego ego we can't fit
together i i know maybe there's stuff
going on behind the scenes we don't know
about maybe they're out about when it's
over no you're right we might you're
right i i haven't got that sense in the
media or just but what we see you know
in a topical view here like like we do
okay but uh i i i i do certainly
recognize there is an issue with the
connection i mean when when odell is
open even last year we talked about this
baker would miss him you know and then
baker would then odell would be covered
and he'd force it to odell and then you
know then it would be two go routes on
each side and the last two connections
didn't work with odell so it's like
baker was scared so he just went over to
jarvis landry and that was the play
odell's wide open he's gone for a
touchdown and he it just it's unreal and
then to your point with the offensive
thing and two and all that
listen you made a lot of good points and
i agree with just about everything you
said
but at the same time they haven't been
with an offensive guy that really knows
how to use a guy like odell beckham jr
anyways i mean we know michael thomas is
getting the ball every week in new
orleans and what happens sean payton
gets him the ball so between freddy
kitchens and now a kevin stefanski who
has not really shown to be that type of
guy or run that type of offense either
you know i don't know if it does fit i
don't know where this goes but i'm gonna
have my eye on it um because i'm
starting to feel like you are you know i
love odell beckham jr uh but it just
doesn't seem like it is working and if
it doesn't start to work soon i maybe i
i might join in the choir with you and
go okay cleveland just cut your losses
see what you can get for this guy
because i think he'll still command a
pretty little asset as far as on the
trade market and you move on with life
send him to new england and and unite
him with cam newton he's desperately
wanted to go to the patriots give him
what he wants get what you can for him
and move on that's what's crazy yes i i
agree and you know what's crazy
is this year right now we can look at
like four marquee teams that i go they
could use odell beckham jr like you just
mentioned one of them cam and the
patriots uh aaron rodgers and the green
bay packers uh russell wilson and the
seattle seahawks and i had another one
and i blanked out but let's just go with
those three because that's pretty damn
good to me anyways all right
um
two more quick points before we break
one
odell beckham jr's body language
suggests he is frustrated and and there
was a moment there was a moment where a
ball was tipped in the air
on the drive where he had the face mask
foul which that face mask may be a sign
of frustration hey it's about time i get
the ball you know down 10 nothing and i
don't touch the ball and now i finally
get it on this stupid little screen pass
where i can run for one yard a ball's
tipped in the air and there was kind of
a a little semi alligator arm yeah a
little hesitant
to go get it like yeah yeah and that
that's that's you
you're one of the great receivers in the
game you don't expect that little half
alligator arm when there's other guys
swarming around uh the drop was
troubling everything was troubling and
here's the other thing too chris they
got this whole array of receivers yeah
paid all the money to austin hooper the
tight end they plucked away from atlanta
they don't need any of those guys what
they do
all they what they could have they could
have won that game if they had just run
the ball and run the ball and run the
ball to nick chubb and kareem hunt
because the ravens couldn't stop him
they stopped themselves when they got
away from the running game and decided
they're going to throw the ball down the
field and and baker mayfield's missing
all these great weapons and either
they're not getting to where they need
to be or he's not throwing it accurately
but the drive sputtered when they tried
to pass yeah i i was a little surprised
with how many times i saw drop back
passes and things like that too this is
one of the reasons listen i'm not a huge
fan of the kevin stefanski offense you
know that i made that known when he got
hired i did think there was maybe a
chance for success because stefanski's
stubbornness
and willingness or whatever to just run
the football and i thought ooh that
could set up for cleveland because they
they the last two years have had a very
good run blocking offensive line and you
just mentioned they got a two-headed
monster a running back that's special so
i thought oh if he plays through that
they might be able to just survive in
the simple
passing schematics of this defense the
fantasy offense but we're seeing for the
second year in a row and i know this is
only game one
but the head coach sees those toys and
they just can't help themselves and they
want to throw the ball when they should
run it and you know stay patient hey
play with the strength of your team and
play through that and that's going to
open up more things but we'll see where
it goes this is going to be interesting
they're too talented for the team to be
getting blown out by baltimore 38-6 i
don't give a damn new coaches whatever
it is that team is too good and too
talented to be losing that way on sunday
well if they would have stuck with the
running game stick with what's working
see that's the problem you spend all
that time and effort concocting this
convoluted game plan and then you get to
the game and everything changes just
like baker mayfield was saying you have
everything schemed up you get to the
game it changes when you get to the game
you got to be ready to pivot to what
works and if the passing game isn't
working and the running game is keep
running the ball because by the fourth
quarter think about how nick chubb yeah
kareem hunt could have worn down the
baltimore ravens defense and demoralized
them but no no they had to pass they had
to throw they had to use those toys
those weapons on offense and that's the
problem of having that many great
players you get yourself in a spot where
you have to keep them all happy because
you don't want to have a problem in the
locker room and now you do because
you're lost and i think they need to
pivot thursday night to chub and hunt
and chub and hunt and if they do that
they're going to be more likely to beat
the cincinnati bank
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports